jour de vote en russie les électeurs de
quarante et une région sont appelés à
élire leurs gouverneurs et assemblées
locales
un scrutin qui intervient en pleine
affaire alexeï navalni les partisans de
l'activiste ont appelé à un vote
intelligent dans l'espoir de faire
chuter les candidats du pouvoir dans le
cadre de la lutte contre 1 de couronnes
un virus les autorités locales ont
autorisé un scrutin sur trois jours et
des bureaux de vote en plein air depuis
moscou furtur notre correspondant en
pointe claire au total bonjour alors
expliquez nous quels sont les enjeux de
ces élections mais bien les enjeux de ce
scrutin sont multiples concrètement il
s'agit de renouveler 18 gouverneurs de
régions une dizaine de parlements
régionaux ou encore quatre députés à la
douma pour de nombreux observateurs il
s'agit aussi d'une répétition générale
avant les élections législatives de 2021
l'occasion donc de mesurer la popularité
ou le désamour c'est selon du parti
présidentiel russie unie à ce titre delà
des résultats qui ne devrait pas
réserver trop de grande surprise il
faudra regarder le taux de participation
il sera aussi intéressant d'observer
l'impact éventuel qu'a eue la sphère
navalni sur les électeurs par exemple
dans la région de novossibirsk troisième
ville de russie où l'opposition est plus
structuré qu'ailleurs et acquis
l'opposant russe avait affiché son
soutien à noter également que dans
plusieurs bureaux de vote des
irrégularités ont été signalées dont
certaines font déjà l'objet d'une
enquête
plusieurs niveaux de lecture donc pour
des résultats officiels qui ne seront
pas connus par tous avant plusieurs
jours
beaucoup font du nucléaire ou depuis on
se trouve